right okay welcome to this simultaneous
meeting of beba district castle cabinet
and mid Suffolk District Council cabinet
may I first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use that you do not interrupt other
speakers that if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave I would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the Internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
castle to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council until the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and/or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded I'd like to make some
introductions now present at the meeting
we have the members of both mid Suffolk
District Council and Baber District
Council cabinets and also the following
officers Arthur Chavo near the chief
executive kathy nixon strategic director
Emily you'll monitoring officer
Fiona Durham L Assistant Director for
economic development and regeneration we
also have Sarah Wilcock assistant
director for customer services Tom Baker
assistant director sustainable
communities and we have Clare Philpott
governance officer in addition we have
following other councillors from both
paper and mid Suffolk we have councillor
Alastair McCraw councillor Rachel Rachel
e Byrne councillor John field councillor
Lavinia Hadding um and councillor Keith
Whelan
I'll now move on to the agenda the first
item apologies for absence and
substitutions now I will now ask the
governance officer to roll call for the
members present okay so I will run
through baby district council numbers
thirst and then mid Suffolk if you could
just say present or yes after your names
called
okay counselor Clive our fee present
counselor Dave Busby resident counselor
Derrick Davis present counselor Michael
Holt yes counselor Elizabeth Mel VZ
present counselor John Osborne present
counselor Lee Parker present counselor
John Ward present okay counsel with
Gerard Brewster prison sorry present
counselor Dooley Flatman present counsel
is Jessica Fleming present counselor
Peter gold present counselor Suzie
Morley present counsel a rich kid sorry
counselor Harry Richardson sorry house
I'm you present okay thank you and
counselor John Whitehead I'm present
thank you thank you Karen
the next night Acton to receive
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by members are
there any to declare okay moving on to
item three then item three is paper BCA
1946 confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the baby cabinet held on the
12th of March 2020 I'll go through the
pages of the the minutes as they're
numbered on mod gov and but as always if
you can let me know if there any points
regarding the accuracy of the minutes so
going forward page 7 page 8 page 9 page
10
page 11 page 12 and finally page 13 so
if there are no points regarding the the
accuracy or the content may I have a
proposal for the minutes please
I propose councillor mal beezy
Thank You castle Avicii and a seconder
Thank You castle holt and baby members
all in favor
yes yes yes yes go through a roll call
Claire yes
this time when I call your name if you
could just reply for against or abstains
so councillor our fee for councillor
Busby for council Davis or councillor
Holt for councillor mouthy ste for
Chancellor Osborne for councillor Parker
for and councillor Ward for I'll now
hand over to counsel and Morley for the
next item Thank You chair now moving on
to item MC a slash 1957 and this is
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the mid suffer district
council cabinet meeting held on the 9th
of March 20 20 again we'll go through
any points regarding the accuracy of the
minutes and this is on the modern guv
papers for mid Suffolk starting at page
7 page 8 page 9 page 10 page 11 page 12
page 13 page 14
page 15 they ask a minor question John
white it for questions of accuracy yes I
mean it's on your minor point and it
rose from looking at page 15 where it
talks about the meeting concluding at
1604 p.m. and I just wondered is there a
reason why we never show when the
meeting starts all very rarely show the
timing of the start of the meeting it's
been inconsistency looking through back
through minutes yes please
I believe it may be because the meeting
starts at 2:30 the start time of the
meeting is at the top of the minutes so
in the introduction of the actual title
of the minutes we would say that what
time the meeting started then it doesn't
does that if you go back to the page 7
occasionally it does but not more often
than not it doesn't right okay in that
case I can add that in each time I think
just for consistent it should be
consistent whatever it is yep yep okay
okay thank you so can I have a proposal
please happy to propose chair Abbott the
second sorry can you say that again I
didn't hear that
I said counselor white I'd have happy to
second okay thank you counselor wanted
so if the governance officer could now
take a roll call thank you okay so again
if you could just say four against I've
stained when I call your name counselor
brewster for councillor ban councillor
ban apologies for Thank You councillor
Flatman for councillor Fleming for
council of gold
councillor Morley for councillor
Richardson or and council a white head
or thank you
so the minutes of the meeting have been
confirmed and will be signed at the next
practical opportunity and are now hand
back to councillor Ward
councillor Ward sorry
I think Thank You castle Molly move on
to item four to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme Norma safe
chair thank you and I'll NAB us over to
council Morley for item five so
questions by councillors governance
officer please okay we've had no
questions from baby district counsel if
I hand over to councillor Eber and for
the first question which is to the
leader of the council thank you very
much Thank You councillor Morley this is
with regards to the item seven on the
agenda I note that there are no there is
no planned full council meeting until
the 23rd of July given that the last
full council meeting was the 27th of
February this will have been a
five-month gap which is not good
democratic practice noting that the
council has only had the power to hold
virtual or remote meeting since 4th of
April in the interest of openness and
transparency to the public please can
you consider holding a meeting before
July and I could also if I may add that
due to the six-month rule you may find
as well at some counselors or at risk of
falling foul of that meeting if they
can't make the july council meeting and
haven't been to a another committee
meeting in the meantime thank you chair
Thank You councillor ebin yes of course
we are we are very happy to consider
having a nerd earlier meeting thank you
thank you for that John me to continue
with question please Kent yes um I note
that the forthcoming decisions list does
not include an item for the next stage
of the joint Local Plan according to the
current local development scheme the
joint local plan should have been
adopted in February 2020 when will a
revised local development scheme be
published giving the public and
developers a more realistic schedule for
the remaining stages Thank You
councillor Boone thank you the intention
can you hear me yes yes the intention
was to review the 10th
following completion of the analysis of
the consultation responses to the 2019
regulation 18 preferred options joint
local plan member engagement on this
remains ongoing as a number of you will
be aware and we are having to adapt our
working practices the result of our
current remote working arrangements
progress is being made on the JLP with
collective input from the JLP member
working group there is current
uncertainty on the timescales and the
impacts of kovat 19
however we will aim to bring a new local
development scheme to the council
meeting in July 2020 given the response
to the previous question it may or may
be to bring a revised scheme to the
council meeting if it's held before due
LOI now thank you very much account
stubborn that's very helpful I think for
your reply would you like to move on to
question 3 think I can't look at Somali
um with regard to the report from the
environmental and climate change task
force which is dirt cabinet on the 6th
of July please could you advise how the
declarations of climate and biodiversity
emergencies and the work from this task
force will be reflected in the next
state of the joint local plan given
there isn't any time current timetable
for this work noted on the forthcoming
decision list and the original time
table has long since passed thank you
very much thank you
even the draft joint Local Plan which we
refer to as the JLP sets out planning
policies on climate change and
environmental enhancement protection and
management in line with both national
policy and local circumstances in
drafting the policies we have also
sought guidance on good working practice
through the planning advisory service
should specific planning policy outcomes
emerge from the task force which differ
from this advice it will be considered
and discussed through the jail pre
member working group Thank You counselor
blown thank you very much of that
counselor burn sir could I just ask a
follow-up to that two counts Smalley yes
so so will the any any kind of outcomes
that are from the task force so that
we'll be able to then it will have to be
quite a quick turnaround to fit into the
schedule for the draft joint local plan
that you outlined in answer to the
previous question so will there be
sufficient time to make any changes to
those draft in that case Thank You
counsel Boone yes sorry I thought
country burn asked you that question
really but I'm not under sir I'm not
quite I'm not quite sure why which is it
to be counselor reburn sorry I'm I was
assuming when the supplementary counts
that burn that given that you'd answered
the the question that you would also
answer my my second row and thank you
did you want me to repeat it
would you mind thank you very much it
was just if the would there be
sufficient time for those you know if
the if there were some planning policy
outcomes from the work of the climate
change task force with would there be
sufficient time to incorporate those
into the draft or local plan bearing in
mind your answer the previous question
it would have to be quite a quick
turnaround and just are people ready to
kind of be able to do that work thank
you very much yeah all right thank you
I think actually it will be helpful if
if I was to bring in officer buck
officer Barker on on this one who might
be able to
give you more of an informed decision
than me would that be possible chairman
bring it sorry to bring in who officer
Barker tombow he's Tom is Tom here I am
on the call if you'd like me to come in
yes please thank you very much Tom sorry
I couldn't see you it's very difficult
to provide a kind of substantive answer
to this on a hypothetical basis it
largely depends on what the suggestions
coming from the task force are how
fundamental they would be to the
strategic policies drafted within the
joint local plan what impact any
suggestions would have on key planks of
the plan and whether those would require
or necessitate further research or
consultancy studies in particular
whether they would impact upon viability
or deliverability of any particular
sites all of those things would need to
be weighed up in terms of the time taken
to accommodate something new within the
emerging joint local plan so sorry that
was a bit wordy in essence it depends
what the suggestions are and how
fundamentally different they are from
what exists in the current plan thing
thank you thank you Tom um before we
just move on to question for Council
reburn I wonder if I can bring in Emily
rule sorry Emily
you'll who can talk to us about the
six-month rule Thank You Tara Thank You
chair and yeah just to provide some
clarity around the six-month rule namely
the counselor must attend a meeting of
the council which includes committee
meetings at least once with any within
any six month period the regulations
that were brought in to deal with
virtual meetings have also extended that
attendance to include attendance at a
virtual meeting so it's not just limited
to meetings over the full council its
meetings of the full council or any
committee or the cabinet's that take
place in a virtual sense
there also remains the ability for the
council to grant the dispensation to
anybody who is unable to attend for one
of the specified reasons Thank You chair
lovely thank you very much Emily um okay
question for councillor eben please um
thank you very much chair this was a
regard to your some substantive agenda
item because there's been a lot of
discussion lately about what type of
skills we have we should be developing
within our district and it's very clear
at the moment that the set of skills
being talked about as essential skills
are vital so I just wanted to ask how
the business grant program will support
essential skills in our district where
those skills have been shown to be much
in need during the current crisis thank
you very much Jeff Thank You councillor
burn councillor Brewster do you have a
response might need to unmute on there
I've already got it the cursor on there
and yes certainly as part of the
emerging emerging economic strategy we
were already looking at how skills
delivery could be expanded within the
districts we were working with Suffolk
County Council local colleges and
university to formulate better and
closer joint working Kovach 19 has
accelerated this work as it is likely
any future recession might result in
higher levels of unemployment and we
want to support people out of work to
access programs to grow transferable
skills resulting in better future
employability we're also keen to develop
programs for new entrepreneurs and to
support those people who wish to start
up their own business organizations such
as innovation labs who offer affordable
hot disk space and virtual membership
alongside programs of business support
are likely to prove vital in supporting
such startups and schools knowledge
required by entrepreneurs
specific grants within the new program
can be accessed by a range of business
startups or SMEs if they satisfy the
criteria to enable him to grow or
develop new innovation or products these
grants in some cases can be used for
training and for skills development of
staff thank you very much - councillor
Brewster oh now I hand back thank you
very much for that
- councillor Ward for item 6 thank you
Thank You council morally right item 6
matters referred by the overview of
scrutiny or joint audit and standards
committees thank you very much thank you
item 7 the forthcoming decisions list
have you all got it in front of you does
anyone have any comments about the
coming decisions list as it's currently
updated no no okay then I will I will
move on right that the next item is is
the substantive item for for this
cabinet there's simultaneous cabinet
meeting and that's paper BCA 1947 the
Baber business grant program and also
MCA 1958 the mid Suffolk business grant
program first of all I will invite the
Baber cabinet member for the economy to
introduce the Baber district council
report Cutler Holt please good afternoon
BCA up at 1946 on my papers Ben you said
1947 yes it is 1946 on the paper
actually in the the agenda since 1947
which is interesting but it's paper 1946
yeah okay thank you I'm pleased to
introduce report BCA 1946 on the new
business grant program for Baylin whilst
we have not had anything like previously
for businesses in baby district
this report seeks agreement for business
grant program that enables small and
medium-sized businesses to access a
range of financial support designed to
meet the very needs whilst delivering
outcomes that meet the counselors
priorities there will be four new grant
schemes to provide support range from
startup to expansion these are firstly
growth an increase productivity fund an
enterprise and Innovation Fund a high
street premises and enhancement fund and
an environmental and sustainability fund
we believe collectively these grants
will enable the following outcomes to
create and sustain jobs enable the
growth of innovation in our businesses
create and retain commercial floor space
access professional advice and the
training access additional funding both
grants and loans improve business
frontage and Town Center Street scapes
encourage the development of
technology-based business solutions
improve environmental outcomes and
carbon efficiencies improve disabled
access and react and be resilient to
change in business landscape whilst this
grant program is not part of the package
of emergency sports-related - Kovach 19
because other national supportive
measures have been put in place to help
businesses through this economic crisis
these business grants will play an
important role in supporting our local
companies to grow and innovate in the
future I believe this new business fund
our commitment to driving growth and
innovation are also recognizing our high
streets needs and encouraging
sustainability and reducing energy costs
in our districts which will be
exceedingly
important follow the impact of Kovac 19
on our business landscape I would like
to conclude by recommending this paper
to members referring to section as 3.1
3.2 3.3 and 3.4 and asks for a seconder
Thank You castle Holt I would be happy
myself to second this report pass over
now to councilor Morley thank you very
much so I would like to now invite
councilor Brewster to introduce the mid
Suffolk District Council report thank
you very much Thank You councillor Morty
and I always turn pleased through
introduce this report on a new business
grants program which will be launched
later in the year the new grants will
provide support for the small and
medium-sized businesses of all sectors
and are designed to help create and
sustain jobs enabling the growth of
innovation in local businesses and help
our companies to react to be resilient
to changing business landscapes the
scheme replaces the previous shopfront
scheme run by mid Suffolk Council which
closed at the end of March this year on
a practical level the support can be
used to create and retain commercial
floorspace be used be used for training
or see new technology and to make
physical improvements to town center
units particularly for those businesses
who want to lower their carbon footprint
or make the Misses more accessible for
all we are allocating 150,000 pounds
over a three-year period in order to
establish the program which will be
jointly run with Baber mid Suffolk and
will be closely monitoring to take up
over the first year so that we can
establish who needs our support the most
we have developed a simple online
application form which will ensure
efficient data capture and enable a
swift response response for to new
requests for funding
there will be for grants to provide
support ranging from startup to
expansion these are growth and increase
Proctor productivity fund for any
business that can demonstrate it is
aiming to increase productivity increase
commercial floor space or create new
jobs or apprenticeships the maximum
grant being 2500 pounds per business the
next one enterprise an Innovation Fund a
grants of up to 5,000 pounds towards
helping new business to utilize
innovative ideas processes or products
the third one
high street premises enhancement fund a
grant towards improvements to the
premises for any local independent
business who owns or rents a shop all
commercial premises in a town or village
center maximum grant here is 2500 pounds
per business and the final one
environmental sustainability services
environmental sustainability fund for
businesses wanting to improve their
environmental performance reduce energy
costs use a renewable energy and lower
their carbon footprint again grants up
to 2,500 pounds per business while this
grant program is not part of a package
of emergency support relation to curve
at 19 because other nationally supported
measures have been put in place to help
businesses through this economic crisis
these business grants will play an
important role in supporting our local
companies to grow and innovate in the
future turning now to the
recommendations at 3:00 on the report
and from the the recommendations from
three one to three point seven I would
like to propose approval of this new
program of support and recommended
financial allocation for our small and
medium-sized business and look forward
to seeing a range of applications when
the scheme is launched later in the year
thank you
Thank You councillor Brewster and can I
have a proposal
I just proposed me provides it yes can I
have a seconder for a mid Suffolk
councillor Molly its councillor
Richardson I'm happy to second
thank you very much councillor
Richardson um councillor Ward right
Thank You castle Morrie what we're going
to do we will have initial questions
from the bailer cabinet members and then
questions from the mid Suffolk cabinet
members before we finally move into a
full debate on on the report or than the
two reports I know one or two people
have already indicated that they wish to
ask questions but what I will do is to
go through each paper cabinet member
individually in alphabetical turn asking
for questions and then castle Molly will
do the same with the mid Suffolk cabinet
members so firstly councillor Alfie do
you have a question Thank You chairman
yes it's a bit of a question bit of a
comment really and it's from the
recommendations and the statement that
we're making fifty seven thousand five
hundred is being made available for
grants that's not quite right is it
because if you look at three one two and
three it's actually a hundred and fifty
thousand pounds will be available in
grants and then seven thousand five
hundred pounds to administer the scheme
that's fine thank you
Thank You councillor ah fee right next
councillor Busby do you have a question
yeah on the conversation thing is is it
gonna be any check on the viability of
companies applying for a grant I'm just
considering me particularly the
shopfronts we want people as a last
desperate throw trying to use it a grant
to keep up an ailing business can
supplies we are yes yes would you like
to come in on that Fiona's without
anything in depth on that and yes good
afternoon councillors and we're just at
the process at the moment of having a
look at what the criteria for each grant
will be because they'll all be
different and it depends on which grant
any particular company has applied for
obviously there'll be a different level
of viability for new startups than there
will for other companies applying for
other types of grants and they'll also
have to provide some match funding so I
think that might help with some of the
viability issues Thank You Fiona
councillor Davis do you have a question
no I'm fine thanks I had a similar
concern as councillor Busby but I'm more
than happy with the answer from Fiona
thank you councillor Holt just to check
whether you have a question or not I
know castle Mel VC any questions no not
really I think the counselor Busby
counselors are the reason the answers
received satisfy me thank you thank you
thanks castle Rose born yes thank you
mr. chairman and yeah what would be able
to amend the grant program in the event
that the type of supports needed may
change as we move into recovery and even
beyond programs pretty set out cancer I
was born in what it's what I use on what
it hopes to achieve a little bit of
flexibility but again I've asked Fiona
it's coming on that because we've been
quite sort of strict about and desires
to where we want it to go to help
companies only to ads that I'm just to
Reese tress that these grants are
obviously not set up to deal with the
emergency around covert 19 they they are
more around encouraging resilience and
growth and innovation across the
district's so they no doubt will form
part of the recovery but they're
certainly not designed to be
at the emergency stage however we have
built in a detailed review at the end of
the first year so that we can assess the
types of grants and the types of
business is applying and we can continue
to shape that fund to ensure that it is
best served for our businesses tonight
can I come in on a supplementary on that
one please councillor Ward certainly yes
yeah no I I do understand and I fully
appreciate that this isn't part of the
current situation that we've gotten that
this grants in place it was more around
making sure that we would be that a
little bit flexible as we possibly even
move out the recovery stage and into the
be on stage if you like because the the
needs and the support may differ to what
it was before we went in and then do
before we approved this um this step
program Thank You council ward okay
thank you
moving on councillor Parker yeah Thank
You chair um my question really is
around accessibility so I've mentioned
in the past that any any sort of scheme
like this and I think it's an excellent
game but any scheme needs to be quick it
needs to be nimble so do we have any
sense of application process time at
this moment in so in a practical sense
if a company were to apply today do we
know roughly how long this is going to
take to process we're talking days weeks
or months on that yes I mean I I think
I'd be wrong if I gave you an actual
time scale here today because I say
we're trying to go through work at the
moment trying to put the detailed
program together and until we had the
decision today it'd be difficult to do
too much beforehand and however we are
unlike previous grants that we've done
we are looking to have it as an online
process and we believe this will speed
up the process considerably it they are
meant to be agile grants that can meet
business needs so we will endeavor to
make sure that they're turned around as
quickly as possible
Thank You Fiona right I'll now hand over
do councillor morally for the mid
Suffolk cabinet member questions Thank
You councillor Ward a councillor
Brewster do you have any questions no I
don't know German Thank You councillor
Bern thank you madam chairman I'm not a
question but it is a comment when
councillor Brewster was giving his
presentation and he was referring to the
recommendations I think he said from
three point one to three point seven but
I could have misheard or he could have
slipped but I just thought I better
mention it in case there had been a
mistake there by either me or him
because in my papers the recommendations
got to three point five yes I believe
that's true
mm-hmm three point five nine madam
chairman goes up to actually three point
seven may I just come in it looks to me
as though the numbering may not be
correct
yes three four and three five is missing
sorry mine mines fine oh yes it goes
from three point three to three point
six I just picked it up this afternoon
when I was doing the presentation
looking at it in modern doc up yes no no
this is one which this is a paper was
actually came or I print it off from for
you and a little bit earlier you may
have that that you might have a previous
version okay okay I think
thank you very much councillor burn
councillor flapman yes chair thank you
Hasler Brewster can you just clarify for
other members and
public that businesses that have already
been lucky enough to apply and and
receive our
shopfront grant will be indeed able to
apply for the new business grants as I
understand it yes the old grant is
obviously finished and the new grants
the four new grants although one part of
them does deal with improvements to
shops but yes they will be able to
reapply for not reapply but apply for
the phret new grants thank you
Thank You councillor flapman councillor
Fleming Thank You chairman and I really
welcome this grant I think the more help
we can give to our businesses and
economy the better I just like to make
up the statement or a point really that
when we do announce it that we're very
clear on what we mean by a small and
medium-sized businesses I know there are
several definitions running round
there's a company's house definition an
EU definition and some others and let's
be clear about what businesses we are
targeting for this and also hopefully we
can be a little bit flexible there yes I
feel sure that that will be taken
account of councillor Fleming and I
would just ask the owner if she has the
idea of what measures the size of the
business and yes I mean we will we're
having a look at that at the moment but
but in reality there it might need to be
a little bit of flexibility around what
constitutes a medium-sized business and
it really depends on the the individual
circumstances of the business and I
wouldn't want to be too defined or it
isn't is for businesses with hundreds of
employees or millions of pounds of
turnover it's really intended to capture
those small and medium-sized businesses
of maybe 50-plus like thank you very
much
Thank You councillor Fleming councillor
gold thank you very much yeah
I start by saying I'm very supportive of
both the report in its recommendations
my question is about how an appreciative
also the fact that the application
process is is to be made it
straightforward as possible my question
is really about how do we have any plans
to take the scheme to businesses as
opposed to wait for applications to
arrive the thoughts I have in mind is
that it's not unknown for good business
support grant schemes to be developed
but then the very low level of
applications to be made against them so
I'd appreciate any any advice on plans
in that regard
thank you I feel sure that we will have
a launch which will certainly publicize
it and going forward the we need it
obviously yes we need to keep that
[Music]
advertising at the grant well up to date
you know I'm just minded but the the
form of shopfront scheme there was quite
a lot of work went into that and and
obviously still businesses didn't
necessarily apply so we'll need to get
across the the ease of being able to
apply for it as well I think sometimes
forms small businesses don't
particularly like filling so yeah I
think we'll be very conscious of this
councillor gold Thank You councillor
Brewster councillor Richardson Thank You
councillor Morley and I too lost every
supporting this program I don't have any
questions in particular but I do have
one or two comments I'd like to make any
debate if possible lovely thank you very
much
councillor whitehead thank you Jim part
comment part question I guess I
certainly welcome this initiative but
give him the uptake of the previous
grant funds you should create this
brought forward fund and it's clear to
me that is the take-up and the outcomes
rather than the potential
are so important so I'm still looking
forward to seeing the report that we
promised at the end of year one I hope
they would also get a report at the end
of year two and I think that a joint
report probably more helpful than
individual reports to the cabinet yeah I
would agree with you there Castle
Whitehead excellent thank you very much
so that's questions from all the cabinet
members if I can now move on to
questions by non cabinet members
counselor field I believe you've got a
question these are small grants you know
a couple of days training or one died of
consultancy perhaps I was just wondering
is there any evidence that grants are
smaller actually required and will make
a significant difference to companies or
is it just so small they won't bother
applying and the second part of the
question really is about the
administration charge I think I heard
someone say seven and a half thousand
pounds is that really a realistic
estimate of the cost of administering
the scheme because you know it takes a
number of days to do most of these tasks
yep I think if doctor last few owners
were answer the second one because
obviously she's closer to that than I am
but yes III think business will be
interested although the grants are
relatively small compared to the the
shop front steam ones but it will enable
some some additional funding to be found
if they're depending on of course how
much they're looking to them to the
business sort of thing but I do think
and believe that we are going into a
different area certainly after covered
we are many businesses and a number I've
spoken to actually and are looking the
same as we are as a District Council to
do things in
in different ways and some funding to
help them do that I think will be very
very welcome
as we go forward Fiona I don't know if
you'd like to add anything or if you
could just go on to the seven and a half
thousand for the administration yes just
around to the first part of the question
we have done quite a lot of consultation
with our partners and people out there
in the market so we've spoken to the new
Anglia and with an incubator
organisation Minter as well as a number
of banks and and they've identified that
small grants are key you know 1999 quit
six of our present of our business basis
is small businesses I think I've got
that figure right can I will correct me
if I haven't and you know sometimes
small businesses they they just need a
bit of seed funding that they can then
lever in other match so part of this is
is how they can use use that small
amount of seed funding to draw in other
funding and but it's also about
confidence so to have someone invest
however small in a small start-up
businesses is quite important and so and
then the second part of the question the
administration cost or what we've learnt
from doing grant programs in the past is
that they even even with an online
version they can take up quite a lot of
time to administer properly and what we
need to be able to do is divert some
officer time to to really administer and
promote these grant schemes properly and
we don't think that seven and a half
thousand per council is is excessive or
for making sure that these grants are
run very as best as they can be
particularly as a society to promote
them taking in to account the earlier
point and so hopefully that answers your
question
thank you you know just make it clear
that I meant the grant the
administration seems far too low not far
to are like seven days of a senior
officers at time yes sorry
is your point yes know where we've we've
assessed it and we believe that the the
online capacity will enable us to give a
part-time officer to work on this which
is why we've come up with the idea of
75,000 per council Thank You Fiona okay
I think now councillor McCraw from from
Baber has a couple of questions he would
like to ask council McCraw thank you
very much John thank you sir both chairs
for indulging me
I just thought there's some useful
points that might be worth clarifying as
a matter of public interest although we
probably understand that these are
coming from unallocated sums I'd like to
clarify the source of these funds
because obviously too many people
because though each council has suddenly
had access to 150,000 I'm assuming it is
each council 150,000 for each council so
I think it'd be useful to clarify that
this is coming from these unallocated
sums that it's included in our existing
budgets now that was a pilot program
that miss rates pilot and that obviously
is now finished
so what consideration has been given for
future replacement funding should these
these funds be successful and another
point I'm sorry to add these all
together but I thought I just get them
out in one splurge you've got um at
50,000 pounds per council per year a
maximum of 20 grants per year per
council at that's assuming the minimum
of two and a half thousand pounds that's
not a heck of a lot of actual grunts 20
is a fairly small number when you
consider the wide areas we cover and
paragraph nine point two suggests that
there might be a need for even smaller
figures of between 500 to 1500 pounds
and has some consideration being given
to weather I mean the need contrary to
what counselor field said that two and a
half thousand might not be enough the
question is in some cases might it be
too much and I just thought all those
points could be
brought out and considered during the
debate Thank You counselor castle Hulk
did you want to respond to that yeah I
can do I would see the future funding it
would have to be able to discussion
amongst each individual council going
forward I mean the funding that we have
announced so far or hope to announce
would be for the three years as I
mentioned the amount of grants well if
this is to be a success and hope that
will be what will be judged on our own
reward sort of thing we'll just have to
see how many grants we do get in and how
popular is I mean taking on board what's
happened in it suffered with their
shopfront grants which wasn't until
recently hugely successful I think we're
gonna have to take you do anything we'll
just see how it goes but some if we if
we do get overcome with with
applications we'll just have to work
with it and go through them and treat
them all on their own merits
you mentioned 9.2 that's referring with
mentor they do go on to say there is a
need for a low-level grants or say to
enjoy an attention to the fact that
these schemes in one to four or maximum
grants so it's not necessary to say that
they'll be - enough thousand four five
thousand sorry Michael and yes I was
just going to add the point that you
just mentioned actually which is the two
and a half thousand is a maximum grant
per business and the indications from
the informal consultation has suggested
that not everybody needs two and a half
thousand pounds some businesses might
need considerably less just to give them
some seed funding particularly those
business startups that's appreciated I
just thought it was a point drawing out
that there are actually levels below the
two and a half thousand pounds that
therefore could spread the wealth as it
were more in a more targeted direction
let's find Thank You Alison right Thank
You councillor McCraw I will now move
into the debate and open this item up
for debate for both councils if any
council would would like to contribute
to the debate debate please indicate in
the conversation pain but I'd like to
just open with it with a comment that
following on from what's been said about
the the level and the size of the grant
it is clear and and I think Fiona and
castle Hulk's have made that very clear
that even small grants two thousand five
hundred or even less can make a huge
difference to some small businesses in
in kick-starting that their ambitions
and so the and obviously the that
success will will have to be judged
after a year two years or whatever but I
firmly believe that we've got enough
evidence to suggest that small grants of
this nature are going to be very helpful
to some of our businesses because we do
have a vast number of very very small
businesses for whom small amounts of
money do do mean a lot and this this
grant program I'm sure is going to to
help them greatly and be a great success
so I've now got a number of members who
wish to come firstly councillor Davis
from from Baber you'd like to make a
comment yeah he's pretty much backing up
what you've just said John because I
think Michael and Fiona have been
working on this for quite a while you
know went way before kovat 19 raised its
its ugly head and I think it's important
because some businesses have been
struggling and while you know we're not
necessarily going to prop up those that
are completely failing as we talked
about earlier but I think it's really
important and also I can member so I
apologize which counsel mentioned it
wouldn't really need to make sure we get
the message out there for businesses
that this is you know well nothing's
ever gonna be back to normal you know
this is to help them you carry on
because we're going to
made a strong economy and this I think
can help Kickstarter in our little area
Thank You councillor castle I'm a VC
thank you very much mr. chairman
I think it's important to recognize that
there has there is currently a lot of
money to help businesses overcome the
issues that covet 19 have have put on
them but the opportunity of these
business grants especially for
shopfronts or what I call high street
facing these are not to repair the
damage of empty properties that have
been neglected for the last 3-4 months
but this these funds these grants are to
help those businesses maybe paint their
shop front so that it catches the eye
it's to help their businesses to develop
so it's a business development concept
as well as innovation Thank You
counselor councillor Richardson you'd
like to make a comment or two Thank You
councillor Ward I just did to talk very
briefly about and express my support for
the environmental sustainability fund
aspect of the program because even under
normal circumstances I would completely
welcome this initiative but I think one
of the things I've been reflecting on is
given the current situation and the
current pressures were under one
potential benefit is we are all required
to adapt to be flexible in the ways that
we work and I think this is although
we're talking about relatively small
sums of money I think this is this is
quite an important kind of an incentive
for for businesses to to innovate and to
change their normal working practices
and that's something that I think in the
longer term could actually be really
significant so I absolutely welcome this
element of the program Thank You
councillor and of course that the other
thing which hasn't hasn't been mentioned
but it is stated in in the papers before
us is albeit that the size
to the the grants are quite small they
will help stimulate businesses to to go
for match funding as well from from
other sources so that's an important
element which we shouldn't be forgotten
does anyone else wish to contribute to
the debate from from either Council my
ID John I'm sorry I haven't got time to
put something in the pie yes counselor
Arthur yes yeah I just say that for
Baber this is a new initiative people
have asked whether it's enough or too
much paragraph 413 in the report you'll
see that we're going to agree how we're
going to monitor this so really it's a
case of suck it and see we'll have a go
and we'll find out whether it's enough
too much and
review accordingly yes that's that's
quite right as with anything like this
any new initiative like this see it
needs careful monitoring and evaluation
and we will respond to to what happens
and if it needs changing if it proves
very successful needs continuing we will
learn again respond if everything needs
to be monitored carefully Thank You
councillor Busby you have a comment
you'd like to make yeah I was just
wondering whether we'd be better spend
the money on subsidizing or sponsoring
apprenticeships in in companies because
bad to have people the desperate for
jobs when we come out of Kovach 19 and
provide free labor for some companies
might might be a good way to go I'll ask
Fiona for a comment on on that but my
inclination is that there is a good
government apprenticeship scheme funded
by the apprenticeship levy on businesses
and I would have thought that should
cover any demand or need for
apprenticeships but you know I don't
know if you'd like to come back with
anything on that please
and I think like comparing slightly
different different things I think the
main issue would be there's probably not
enough money to make much of a
difference in terms of apprenticeship
support there are as you say other
programs of support out there for for
businesses looking to take on
apprenticeships but some of our small
but fast growing businesses who may only
have one or two employers are probably
not at a point where they could consider
apprenticeship friendships but they
could be you know fantastically
innovative and coming up with new
technology products for example so I
think it's it's something we will
continue to talk to partners around in
terms of apprenticeships going forward
the important thing I think which will
come out of covert 19 and in the impact
is the ability to have transferable
skills and and there is an element of
these grants which will allow for
upskilling or Barker to skills is
exiting FLE hopefully that will then
that will address that point but I don't
I don't think there's enough money here
to specifically have a an apprenticeship
program Thank You Fiona right does
anyone else wish to contribute to the
debate if not then we will move to to
the vote and I will therefore ask the
governance officer to conduct the roll
call vote and for for each council
Claire
okay Thank You chair so again I will
call your name and if you could apply
for against all abstain councillor our
fee for councillor Busby fool councillor
Davis poor councillor Holt Oh
councillor Mel VC for councillor Osborne
for councillor Parker for any council
award well
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you
and now for mid Suffolk councillor
Brewster for councillor burn or
councillor Flatman for councillor
Fleming for councillor gold for council
Morley for councillor Richardson for
councillor Whitehead for and again
that's unanimous chair Thank You Clare
right well that concludes this
simultaneous cabinet meeting of the baby
and mid Suffolk cabinets the dates and
times for the next meetings mid Suffolk
on the 8th of June and Baber on the 9th
of June and both of those will be
conducted via Skype I would now like to
thank everyone for attending the meeting
and for all their contributions and I
will close the meeting now thank you
thank you thank you